we got Christen weler here you think the
Democrats would actually hire Greg
Gutfeld to toast a democratic debate
they wouldn't do it and so the fact of
the matter is I mean Christ I'm going to
use this time because this is actually
about you in the media and the corrupt
media establishment ask you the Trump
Russia collusion hoax that you pushed on
this network for years was that real or
was that Hillary Clinton made up
disinformation answer the question go Mr
sorry several of those people on that
stage are just auditioning for for their
next TV contracts and Vivic is one of
those that ramas Swami is a symptom of
something else the weakness of the rest
of them in in Old Times he'd be gone
because he was a clown the problem is
he's so
annoying I'm beginning to think the
media is kind of starting to warm up to
him joining us now the aformentioned V
ramaswami oh V they're after you uh VI
for people who missed it this was the
moment that really sent everyone into
the
stratosphere she made fun of me for
actually joining Tik Tok while her own
daughter was actually using the app for
a long time so you might want to take
care of your family
first uh couldn't you have made that
point without invoking her
daughter well look I think actually the
point is not a criticism of her daughter
Laura it was a criticism of Nikki Haley
because I am also on Tik Tok the point
I've made is that we as Republican
primary voters and Republican leaders
need to reach the next Generation so the
fact of the matter is Nikki Haley often
talks about a new generation of
leadership the problem is she's on the
wrong side of that generational divide
with an astounding lack of
self-awareness criticizing other people
for not looking after their kids or
their families for use of social media
or Tik Tok when in fact that is a gaping
hole that does deserve and be bar and
Merit mention and I also don't want to
hear somebody like Nikki Haley get in a
high course you know she uses her pest
to talking points with respect to Hunter
Biden all the time so if you can't
handle the heat I think you stay out of
the kitchen she's called me four-letter
words in each of the last two debates I
can handle it but if you can't dish it
then you you you can dish it you better
be willing to take it that's what I say
there's a presidential contest and if
you want to sit across the table from
Shin ping you better better have a spine
and get ready to get ready to roll yeah
she called you scum I'm not sure anyone
would get away with calling so maybe
maybe Trump would I don't know it just
it was it was uncomfortable for people
to watch but I I get your point but then
this new National poll Washington Post
iOS came out of likely voters vake who
watched the debate they found that you
came off more
negatively than
most your reaction to that well I mean I
was I was criticizing everybody 360
degrees on the stage I want
accountability for the chair of the RNC
I was the only one who on that stage
called for what I think we require new
leadership at the RNC Rona McDaniel took
over in 2017 2018 2020 2022 2023 losses
or losing of our expectations is that a
positive fact no it's not Laura but the
underlying reality is not positive so
I'm not going to put positive she on
something that requires accountability
and the same thing with respect to NBC
news or the other candidates on that
stage so when when we require making an
actual observation where the underlying
truth is negative I'm not going to
sugarcoat it U Ron McDaniel responded uh
to your comments today watch he's at 4%
he needs a headline I'm going to say
what I've been saying to Republicans all
along our headline should be about Joe
Biden but I also will stand by my record
as RNC chair now the RNC doesn't do
state races we're a federal committee so
we weren't involved in those races on
Tuesday I know V's kind of newer to the
party he voted for Obama so he may not
know that I've been elected four times
unlike somebody else who came after me
last night she's been elected four times
V what's your response to that well
first of all I find the outright lying
ridiculous I've never voted for Obama in
my life so for a chair of the RNC to be
saying that on National Television is
malpractice as it was also malpractice
for her as the Press reported last night
she's supposedly cheering and booing
against me in the middle of a debate
think about that there's a chair of the
RNC and saying that they won't be giving
me another Penny of their money she
almost proves my point about the
corruption it's not her money and that's
the way the people in this party have
thought about this for a long time they
think it belongs to them doesn't it
belongs to the voters the actual base
that we're supposed to serve and when
you have a managerial class a swamp
within the Republican party that has
lost its way so badly longing to go back
to an older era of establishment quasi
corruption yes we require new leaders
who will lead this party forward that
requires people coming from the outside
and from the Next Generation that's why
I'm in this Laura and I think that
that's what's going to be required to
revive the Republican party and to
revive this country and if you look at
that debate stage last night it's a good
example of even the moderator selection
to the comments that she made afterward
that prove my point yeah the National
Review editorial board it's it's
establishment outfit but they accused
you of pandering to the isolationist
inclined populace of your party and
claims that all you want is a future
media gig do you want a future media gig
VI I don't I think what I want is to
revive this country and fact of the
matter is that's a long-winded way a
very National Review esque way of saying
that I am at giving the GOP Primary
voters and the people of this country
what they actually want rather than Dick
Cheney 2.0 which is crawling all over
that debate stage last night the reality
is we are fighting Foreign Wars in
places like Ukraine that have not advanc
the American interest and I don't want
to see Iraq 2.0 or Afghanistan 2.0 with
7 trillion added to our national debt
and thousands of people my age that were
sent to die America sons and daughters
in wars that didn't Advance the American
interest why don't you think
you if your view is so popular obviously
Trump's the big dog in the in the pen
but why why are you not doing better in
the
polls I think there are two solid
America First candidates in this race
that's Donald Trump and myself and the
voters face a choice in Donald Trump's
case they get somebody who's tried and
true and he was a good president that's
why he's doing so well in the polls I
have something that he doesn't I have
fresh legs I'm young and my belief is it
will take somebody from the Next
Generation to reach the next a and
revive national pride and I'm new so I
think Laura we're going to be very
successful heading into the Iowa caucus
and otherwise but I'm going to keep
speaking the truth be unvarnished and
unconstrained about it I think that's
what our voter base wants rather than
doing these PLL tested slogans to try to
you know solve for what the
establishment Media or the donor class
wants me to say doesn't work that way
with me and I think that's what our base
wants as long now with all these
three-inch heel comments I hope there's
no Halloween you know costume from years
ago of you and heels okay cuz that would
really send everybody into into the
orbit okay so uhk thank you for joining
us tonight we appreciate it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else